three things we know about John Bongiovi
he loves his music his family and his
every Saturday two of those three things
allow him to live every dad's Johnson
please football at Notre Dame and I'm
not calling him Rudy but he kinda is
just there every weekend though rooting
him on we talked all about that but
first John and I got real about his rock
relationship gone wrong Richie Sambora
leaving the band said it from day one we
had no ill will he just didn't show up
for work anymore but Sambora did post
this video to John over the summer
congratulations on the new single man
have you guys talked recently no um but
he's weak you know he sent out that
thing saying how much he liked the song
and I responded to it he never called
anyone in the band again for three and a
half years we never saw him again it's
just okay your journey took you
somewhere else
that new single is this house is not for
sale from the upcoming album of the same
name and some of the lyrics to living
with the ghosts apply to Ritchie's
departure
[Music]
well you know you can imagine who the
ghost is in the song you know being in a
rock bands not a life sentence you
choose to share your art and you do it
till the day you don't choose not to do
it any longer at a happier event at a
friend's son's wedding earlier this year
John had a new singing partner
[Music]
sort of shook my head long Wow here's
gonna be a unique version his own
marriage to Dorothea is one of the
strongest in show business but what's
the secret you know I'm just a lucky guy
I got it right the first time it's that
simple and you know and I wouldn't trade
it and they're 21 year old son Jesse
Bongiovi plays football for Notre Dame
like you get dressed up in gold and you
call the Notre Dame swag the man could
ever want you're just one of the dads
but then the marching band starts
playing Prairie
[Applause]
write a song daddy play yours too
[Music]
you